I have a question for you and this
fascinates me first of all
congratulations but you're on a stamp on
the Ivory Coast the Ivory Coast has put
you on a postage stamp bring this up for
a reason through the second guest I've
had on in about a month
who's brought this up because some a
Blair was here and she's also on a stamp
in the Ivory Coast oh no I don't think
that really looks like some a Blair but
anyway these are real we didn't make
these up these are real steps and they
don't contact you guys because they
could send a letter with your stamp on
it and then you'd know yes and they
could ask you permission or tell you why
they're doing it I have been to I've
been to and Africa's beautiful I've been
to South Africa once I don't have a
connection to the beautiful ivory guys
it's fascinating I have no idea why they
put it feels like a high honor though
right huge like I feel like you know a
queen yeah well congratulations cuz this
guy is also on a stamp in the Ivory
Coast and so badly want to be on a stamp
on the Ivory Coast you know well I think
it might could happen how do I do that
don't know you know I did what do I
contact if anyone is watching you has
any kind of contact at all with Ivory
Coast I will do anything to get on a
postage stamp I don't think you'd fish
on the stamp you say my face is cute I
might have to cut your hair off hey but
it was two stamps on one there's this
stamp and then there's just this stamp
right here and you're gonna get both and
put it together yeah exactly so a lot of
money on steps there
you